anyway Sims talk today is entitled those
damn pictures Rob Rogers mr. oh and I
mean I guess I'm in an in an enviable
position of having to follow Rob but it
won't be hard because I'm you were all
having such a good time that we only
have one direction to go as a general
rule of thumb editorial cartoons or only
as memorable as their nemec's if the
ruling classes are obdurate hypocritical
or corrupt cartoonists tend to outdo
themselves your satire exaggeration and
sarcasm this is by the way the first
editorial cartoon we know up okay Rob
Rogers of course is probably one of the
few people who mourns the departure of
George Bush from the White House in the
same way that her block wept when Nixon
died happily history like Sarah Palin
has a way of repeating herself and
political cartooning we'll live to fight
another day historically political
cartooning in the english-speaking world
dates back 12 or the press dates back to
the 1700s from the imbecilic reigns of
the Kings George notable for their
tendency to lose control of bodily
function and overseas Empire with equal
aplomb the Georges reigned over the
first great period of Western political
satire fostering a coterie of artists
who commented upon the changing British
world this by the way is a official
portrait of Robert Walpole this is not
an official portrait of but it's the
same man contempt of the aristocracy is
nothing new but circumstances conspired
to at william Hogarth and his
contemporaries to sell let william
Hogarth and his contemporaries to sell
prints without hanging for it first the
monarchies power diminished with the
legitimization of dissent second the
public was becoming literate urbane and
wealthier finally printing paper making
and distribution we're changing making
the wider dissemination of graphic
material possible this is oh how do you
go back
left arrow should go back thank you ah
thank you along with the powder this is
probably william Hogarth most famous
image of gin lane what happened to
London after the introduction of cheap
gin along with the powdered wig and
smallpox cartooning jumped the Atlantic
to take up residence in the colonies
while cruickshanks comic Almanac helped
redefine the genre in England scurrilous
illustration and scurrilous illustration
had its place in the Republic the early
19th century is generally considered a
nadir for the wiseass pictorial in
America the insufferably virtuous
founding fathers made poor targets and
even today as Paul mentioned scholars
scratched their heads when looking at
drawings of Andrew Jackson and the
sanket second bank crisis like graphic
pornography its spiritual twin
Illustrated political commentary
remained the province of the Congo sent
a print technology made dissemination
problematic by the 1840s American
newspapers were evolving from mercantile
broadsheets to partisan tabloids that
fought for circulation using scoops
special editions and outright falsehoods
the penny press had no time for pictures
which needed to be copied transferred to
wood block and cut to fit column leads
instead illustration found its home in
the magazines that emerged in the
antebellum period including Frank
Leslie's illustrated magazine and
Harper's Weekly most pictures were being
provided by itinerant journalists
several of whom were beginning to
specialize in illustration including
Frank Baloo Alfred whoa and Thomas Nast
a German immigrant who had them would
miss spent his youth on the streets of
Manhattan and was already a familiar
face along newspaper roll row and this
is NASA was a great draftsman this is
one of his illustrations for Harper's of
a grand review of the Republic of the of
the Army of the Republic but possessing
wicked talent and derisive wit Thomas
ness one between sentimentalism and wrap
your like political commentary his two
most famous images remain current he
identified the Republican Party with its
elephant as an allusion to wartime
sacrifice in the 19th century seeing the
elephant was a phrase which wasn't with
and it was a colloquialism for engaging
in battle and the late
19th century the elephant comes out as a
Republican to remind people that the
Republicans won the Civil War and more
familiarly transmogrified st. Nicholas
into our avuncular Santa Claus like a
good duelist Nast had the luck to draw
at the right time the United Nations was
undergoing an unprecedented wave of
immigration and the Illustrated
newspapers became a conduit for
Americanization Rob is not the first
person to comment upon the relationship
between the Catholic Church and children
publishers such as William Randolph
Hearst and Joseph ulit survived for
readers by any means and this is
important because the technology start
to change eventually freed from the
constraints of veracity by photography
illustrators in dolton caricature
invention and humbug but most
importantly was the villain and there
was William Marcy tweed the Gilded Age
plutocrat who had the misfortune to be
the chair of the Democratic Party of the
state of New York and thus grand sachem
of Tammany Hall while Nast was on deck
Nass portrayed tweed and his cronies as
burglars thieves walking bags of graft
co-conspirators and recently convicts
after Nast the stable of editorial
cartoonists generally devolved into a
bunch of quislings who depicted topics
as compelling as the course of empire
and the virtue of the Panama Canal part
of this might have had to do with the
rise of new media since photography had
matured the telephone was making instant
communication available and the movies
became their ascendancy after the turn
of the 20th century indeed we have
President McKinley on film not that
anybody really cares talented
cartoonists found new markets for their
work sunday supplements carried comic
strips magazines particularly The New
Yorker printed sophisticated caricature
an animated film and comic books became
major industries this is Peter Arno
who's actually a personal favorite of
mine he's an old new yorker cartoonist
but our know is pleasant and funny but
he's not really that critical of the
rich he proceeded escribes but then
something happens and enter her block in
maudlin her
the pen name of Herbert block was
already publishing cartoons by the age
of 19 when he was hired as a replacement
the chicago news in 1929 politicized by
the depression he became advocating for
New Deal reforms and against Nazi
aggression in Europe after mustering out
of the service in 1945 he left the
syndicate for the Washington Post where
he continued to publish cartoons until
his death in 2001 per block lives
forever bill maudlin was born in New
Mexico in 1921 and began producing
cartoons for the army in 1940 after
participating in the invasions of Sicily
in Italy he was hired by stars and
stripes where he earned the wrath of
General Patton for criticizing the chain
of command and the innate wisdom of
military intelligence now I don't know
how these are come out these are some
maudlin ones I copied and I was not very
happy with the quality but one of the
things one of the things I sort of
noticed was how much he started to look
like old wood block prints and I thought
that was kind of a fascinate and
something I had never seen in his work
before his drawings of two dog-faced
inferring infantrymen Willie and Joe
continued to personify the ordeal of
servicemen under fire after the war he
went to he was had a long career and won
his second pew litter in 1959 he died in
2003 by recapturing by recapturing the
sardonic voice of the overlooked maudlin
and her block helped reinvigorate the
cartoon as a political art form working
in an era of liberal ideals and
oversized villains both artists so
heroism emerged from the prosaic actions
of everyday people and trusted that the
seemingly insurmountable obstacles of
depression World War racial
discrimination or nuclear annihilation
could be ameliorated by the application
of hard work and common sense not that
they didn't have a lot of fun along the
way her block in particular seemed to
rejoice in exposing the opportunism that
fueled richard nixon's political career
this was a love story I mean this is
this is like 1956 this is 1973 for 20
years her block just went after Nixon
you know it was it was it was a lot of
fun too and it's a lot of fun to kind of
look
over time but to return to the subject
at hand he wouldn't remember but I once
asked Rob Rogers why his people were so
lumpy he his characters inhabit a world
many of us know quite well that of
spreading waste lines imperfect
orthodontia ill-fitting clothes and bad
hair happily everyone gets the same
treatment whether they're the search
oracle challenged denizens of brood on
grant or there's innately elegant public
figures people like Ronald Reagan and
Barack Obama I suspect there's a reason
for all this bad tailoring it
immediately makes a subject both suspect
and human and more importantly leaves
room for error who hasn't realized that
our fly is open at the lectern or that
we've just completed a job interview
with spinach and our chief rhetorically
there's a little bit of whoopee cushion
in all of this and if his occasional
butt crack is any indication I'd argue
that Rogers owes a great stylistic debt
to Don Martin the late cartoonist of Mad
Magazine and of course Rogers is wise
true members core constituency of
western Pennsylvania oddly a population
that has been promised the return of
Industry the realignment of the service
economy and the rise of the creative
class by a group of lungs who solutions
have all shored jobs facilitated
emigration and proclaimed that the
world's biggest brownfield is in fact
each autopia has somewhat have have
somehow developed an affinity for
sarcasm besides a little ridiculousness
as a satirist stock and trade while
historians are loath to talk in
generalities the rise and fall of
Fortune tend to produce social friction
new economic functions emerge migration
fuels increased heterogeneity and the
inevitable scramble for resources labor
and land with the resultant winners and
losers tends to produce social
situations and processes that are unique
and difficult to decipher to joke to
quote Jacob bronowsky the British
polymath satire is a mode of challenging
accepted notions by making them seem
ridiculous it usually occurs only in an
age of where there exists no absolute
uniformity but rather two sets of
beliefs and of course
Rogers kinds of knows this sarcasm and
satire and irony kind of run of course
run through his work of the 21 hold
sufficient power to suppress open attack
but not enough to suppress veiled what
veiled ones further satire is intimately
connected with urbanity and
cosmopolitanism and assumes a civilized
opponent who is sufficiently sensitive
to feel the barbs of whipped to hold
something up to ridicule presupposes an
age of reason in which everyone accepts
the notion that conduct must be
reasonable in an era where social
observation seems to be largely
determined by sick of fancy Orban
allottee rogers has combined the graphic
verb of mass the graphic verb of Nast
the London procharged on and the
idealism of her block and coincidentally
like Hogarth he's had a moronic George
to work with as well god bless him for
him professor of heart who's ready no
school of are a kind of well-known
artist
work in a variety of media Pat is well
known for a variety of media from
drawings prints and paintings and I
counted on the web about 500,000 550
solo exhibitions from 1980 spread big
deal reactions to her work are quite
striking wonder it has described her
paintings as they quote mixture of TS
Eliot poetry and slang another describes
her recent work as quote formulas canon
mean zoological illustration penetrated
by medieval spiritualism and gloss with
personal dreams which compact and
describing herself writes that she finds
slowing down to make sure that you can
get your tiger how to describe yourself
twice that she finds absolute
exhilaration in mark making from the
control and academic to the childlike
and spontaneous I often look to the work
at outsider artists for inspiration and
oh okay hats talk today is entitled
robbery cartoons and comics it's a yep
you need help yeah we're revamping the
funniest moment about me when the
cartoonist come in
so while this is going on I'm going to
say something at our space or export the
end which is we have this workshop on we
have a workshop on saturday morning
beginning at ten o'clock going someone's
help cartoonist for a day you can sign
up and you can work not exactly one on
one the 20 on one with Rob Rogers into
your own political cartoon there's
limited space there are still spaces
available and if you're interested in
that you can contact the product
information is on our poster is Tom
justjust afin just something i did email
addresses Jonathan j ust osin @ gmu.edu
so please get in touch as soon as
possible so you can have one of the few
remaining spots Halloween today and as I
mentioned past talk today is entitled is
it o is hesitation is entitled thievery
cartoons and comics in contemporary I
begin by i offer my talk almost as an
apology and a welcome to rob rogers
political cartoonist regular cartoonist
political satirist throughout history
all the areas of Fine Arts have used the
word appropriate to take each other's
work musicians have stolen from other
musicians architects have used other the
work of other architects that the area
of Visual Arts is God has used the
safety of real life umbrella of
appropriation as a convenient aphasia to
borrow and steal from ideas from other
artists and many sources without any
kind of apology or respect and probably
the area that has been mine and thunder
the most is the creative work with
cartoonists comic strip strip creators
and political cartoonists the stealing's
going on for a long time with without
much reciprocal respect in truth it's
really thievery
when we talk about contemporary art one
of the top and again a lot of artists
have used appropriation but probably one
of the first people that does come to
mind is Roy lipid steam and this is a
piece that he did in 1963 and early pop
art image and he frequently stole images
I probably familiar with a lot of the
the more comics that he stole from in
this case he sold this is from a comic
book called the star jockey it was
written by me and me IRA Novak and if
you have a chance to look at it it's a
65 panel comic book all beautiful
illustrations like this liechtenstein
went on to become a wealthy man and mr.
Novak basically made a living on we
always artists used the idea of
appropriation and kind of kept an ironic
stamps from the people that they miss
you like from more could to computer
up here at like you makin it up through
this kind of moves on a little bit
further on Philip Guston worked began
out to achieve notice in the early 30s
as a painter painter with imagery and
then as the 50s approached he became
part of the abstract expressionist
movement primarily more color field in
the 60s then he did almost an about
change and kind of began to reflect back
on some of the imagery that he did in
the 30s but really began to much closer
the work of comic book artist political
satirist and cartoonists and this is one
of his early paintings when something
else he also began to work directly with
a lot of writers and I think in this
piece of work he started with Clark who
lead she spent a lot of time with their
top poet Coolidge and they really began
to work together in tandem a writing
spontaneous poetry and Philip coming off
of sort of the ideas and I think there
was a reciprocal exchange going on
Dustin was aware of Mad Magazine and in
return the artists of madman
very much aware of Gustav so there was a
little bit of back and forth
um in night around 1968 Philip Guston by
very disgusted with the entire art scene
and moved to Woodstock New York of all
appropriate places and it became very
good friends with Philip Roth the writer
and he also became very disgusted with
Richard Nixon and over a period of three
or four years they would meet once a
week for dinner talk politics how much
they hated the war and Nixon and I think
this is again an example it's probably
one of 30 of the series called poor
Richard where he really worked very
closely but you can see his work in it
but again you can see the images and the
kinect connections to Don Martin in math
magazine and I'm pretty sure you know
obviously that's Nixon I think one is
John Mitchell and the other Spiro Agnew
of their prime needs no explanation this
is one of the series gets it
and the kitchen probably that were on
automatic andhra kissinger from that
series this is a work he got to did with
another pelican writer William Corbett
that came at the same time also along
that time period something really nice
happened for cartoonist and this is an
image from the Perry food and the Harry
who was a group of Chicago images
painters and they not only stole from
comic book and political satire and
political cartoonist they embrace them
and they did a number of shows together
they were sort of some of the early
people to say wow you guys can draw as
well as we do you know come on into the
Academy join us in the museum you're
part of our shows I think they stole the
little DC comic book
at the same time there was still a lot
of shows going on with work of artists
that were influenced by comic book
artists and political cartoonist that
really kept the people the real
cartoonists the real political
cartoonist and sapped iris kind of
outside the door and oddly enough this
is a sculpture done by Robin page of
fluxes artist and the title of the piece
is called there's a lot of art around
these days that's not getting the kind
of recognition it deserves and they
invited the trip ended up they invited
all of the comic book artists and the
political cartoonists to come to the
show and there was sort of a turn of
events and the comic Bogardus the
political satires were so excited and
they got there and they realized they
were sort of there to say look look at
these poor keep people that were working
with so the respect kind of went back
and forth and it was sort of even a
heartbreaking moment for a lot of the
writers a lot of shows came and went
where people were in a side-by-side the
political cartoonist the so-called fine
artists but a big show happened in one
can call pulp pulp fiction and it really
made this big effort to say look we're
all equals we're stealing from
do you bother you know you take from us
but we're all equals and called fiction
showed work of bats about bad boy artist
Mike Kelly who used the comic format he
used the comic political cartoon format
to even dis the art world another artist
that was in it was Raymond Pettibon who
started out as a cartoonist posters for
the early punk rock group Black Flag
carry James Marshall a painter who later
he began to use the comic book format to
get his politics and work with
communities and they were sailing world
side of ours from this is Joe Sacco it's
a full political cartoon book I'm Way
behind on my notes and I just wanted to
give a personal set aside that our crumb
has made me read the Bible
and it's not funny around nineteen
eighty and this is a horrible I could
not find a better reproduction of this a
wonderful artist named Tim Rollins Tim
Rollins and Kos and kls stands for kids
of survival and tim robbins called
himself an educator a conceptual artist
that used education to create partner
and in a very quick nutshell Tim Rollins
was in one of the worst so-called more
schools in the Bronx and he was given
the so-called worst kids in the school
and they said they probably can't even
read and he brought to them he had been
really looks like Kafka's America and
the Invisible Man and in this case they
read Animal Farm and you can probably
all I can really pick out with the blur
is Castro and a few other political
of the time this is from about 1984 and
they're probably about 20 paintings in
this series and and one of the great
things that he did whether it was
stealing or I think he did a lot of this
as a huh at a diner some of the artists
he had the kids study JJ Granville who
was a political cartoonist from French
cartoonist from the 1830s and you can
see the kind of the anthropomorphic
animals he's a little bit sweeten his
illustrations but I think you can get
the effect that he really didn't think
much of school it's another grandville
mother Granville and then he also also
have a look at Thomas Nast and get here
a couple these are from the series that
they did in nineteen
for and I think they're there there's a
very specific drawing by Nast somewhere
where he is using the dog figures so the
students learn you know a good bit about
the political history of political
cartooning there's one of both up and
they revisited an animal farm in during
the campaign and guess who that is not a
little boost turns over there with John
McCain just sort of a very quick aside
with these paintings and all of the
things that that Tim Rollins and Kos did
they were able they've sold for so much
they've been able to build their own
school and bring in the Bronx and many
of the kids that participate been able
to go
to college a few years back I did a
residency at a school and I walked into
the studio and there was a great little
sign magic marker on the wall that said
it's never too late to procreate and I
did what I thought was the only thing
you could do I stole the sign but but
being Catholic I fessed up to the
morning I had it but I am fest I'm
fessing up here that that I've been
guilty that I've appropriated from comic
book artist and political cartoonists
madrone this is one of my drawings and
it's called worn by proxy spy versus spy
and the term that I use 5 vs spy comes
from one of my favorite cartoons I grew
up with Mad Magazine and every kind of
comic book imaginable there is always a
stat this high in in my house and my
parents just figured well at least
they're reading
and I mean I didn't learn the classics
because of the series of classic comic
books but the appropriation goes on
because there's a theory that I don't
have my notes here but the the person
that drew the Spy vs spy was a Cuban
nationalist that immigrated to the
United States in 1963 in a during that
amid the cold war but there's a theory
that he took the faces from the old
people of the Black Plague herb stuffed
masks so I decided I was going like my
work even better with some really
serious appropriation and the idea from
mine was that the idea of war by proxies
of people standing off to the side and
they look to the center and they seek
evil and I say to rob thank you I think
you're that person in the eve
in the middle you don't always keep the
thank God you don't always keep the left
on their toes but you're certainly
keeping your right on thanks Rach
questions for robber for powder for Tim
she was all stand up no any questions
and of course bill Geragos request I
should also mention no I think I mean I
do self-censor all the time but I think
it's more about about taste and making
it something that gets my point across
and is understandable it's less about oh
I would never draw something like that I
mean clearly I'm not going to draw
something you know like my editor said
you know I a couple a couple months ago
I got the cover of City Paper's let me
do the cover because we're doing the
story in the book and I said to my
editors it okay if I go over the
competition exists and he said yeah he's
like just just keeping a good taste no
no pornographic Santa Claus or anything
like that you know because they have
different standards over there so so I
edit myself in terms of the standards of
our newspaper sure I mean but but now I
mean I think it's
I'm certainly I'm a I'm a human being
who had certain sensitivities and
certain things offend me but I try to
push it as far as I can go but I do
self-censor more for content and humor
and and whether whether whether the
drawing you know whatever image i'm
showing with misdirect people away from
me from what the message is and lose
them you know the kind of danger early
and you pointed at my people really yes
but that's why I pointed the lynching
cartoon I knew that that was going to
cause a stir and that just by showing
that image was controversial you know
because I mean I don't know if you're
mad at the show the world you know they
went to other place other cities but it
was the lynching photograph and some
people thought we shouldn't have exhibit
just as long to show those images but I
think it's important to remind people of
history so for me it was it was you know
I wanted the cartoon to run but but the
editors decided to show it to all the
african-american writers and editors at
the paper sadly she wasn't that many I
wish it was more of it you know so they
showed it to everyone there and they all
said they also sort of did the same
thing they went whoa and then I said but
it's a good cartoon should run you know
so after after that I felt like it was
okay but you're right i mean there's you
kind of run the risk every time you do
something whether people are going to
get it and appreciate it or or not